[Musique]
dans quelques jours les téléspectateurs
seront qui deviendra la nouvelle Miss
France bonsoir Sylvie bonsoir
Jean-Pierre bonsoir la France mais cette
93e édition du concours est surtout
marquée par le départ d'une figure
emblématique du comité Sylvie Tellier un
départ qui selon certains seraient dû à
des tensions entre elles et Alexia la
roche-joubert une incompatibilité entre
Alexia la roche ober et vous des
tensions qui auraient finalement éclaté
au grand jour devant des journalistes
lors de la traditionnelle conférence de
presse vendredi dernier ou le ton serait
rapidement monté entre les deux femmes
Sylvie Tellier aurait même fini cette
conférence de presse vexée et excédé par
des propos d'Alexia Laroche-Joubert il
faut avoir de la considération pour tout
le travail fait pendant 17 ans
alors je vais regarder le sujet qui a
compris l'embrouille c'est quoi
l'emboitier les masques tombent en fait
Alexia Laroche
depuis le départ et là lors d'une
conférence de presse publique Alexia à
osé si je puis dire exprimer à Sylvie tu
n'as jamais produit l'eau chaude en gros
tu n'as jamais rien fait tu étais
inutile donc les deux ce sont clashés
publicment mais il y avait tellement de
ressentiment chez Sylvie qu'à un moment
ça explose
toutes les deux avec respect elles ont
voulu faire ce conflit mais c'était une
haine terrible parce que est-ce que ça
t'empêcher de passer un bon weekend
je me rends compte que ces deux femmes
sont des femmes de pouvoir et en fait
quand on a du pouvoir on a de l'ego et
finalement quand on voit que deux femmes
comme Daniel qui se ressemblent au final
elle devrait s'aimer parce que deux
femmes qui se ressemblent elles ont des
points communs et c'est rare maintenant
dans ce monde des femmes qui s'aiment
parce que là on voit et elle prouve
malheureusement que bah dans cette vie
et dans le monde dans ce monde de la
télé au final elles sont sympas
séparément et elles se détestent parce
qu'au final elles ont le même rôle le
même mouvement
il y a des gens qui sont hyper sympa
séparément et quand ils sont ensemble
c'est horrible moi j'ai côtoyé pendant
des années beneutz
c'est la naïveté la naïveté au service
de leviol je connais je pense que
Mathieu je pense que je connais bien le
dossier tu peux je vous le dis non il
pouvait pas avoir Sylvie et Alexia et
Alexia et c'était on devait avoir ou
Alexia aussi vite c'est aussi lui
rentrer dans le moule d'Alexia ou bien
Alexia la dégagé donc forcément un
moment Alexia a dit bon il va falloir se
il va falloir il va falloir se
débarrasser de Sylvie voilà et je
comprends Alexia après si elle arrive
pas travailler avec elle mais c'est
Alexia la patronne c'est elle qui a
décidé de voilà de de sortir Sylvie mais
c'est pas du tout Sylvie qui est parti
tout seul si ça se passait bien c'est
Miss serait resté hein Alexia
diverses personnes qui viennent la vie
et qui aime Alexia la rochebert qui a
fait un excellent travail sur les
différentes productions
[Rires]
comme ça au détour d'un couloir et je
suis très heureux voilà et ça va très
bien se passer c'est quand c'est le 17
décembre
vous verrez et on verra et on en
reparlera